The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to
lecture number 8.
In this lecture, I would like
to discuss with you the
numerical integration and some
modeling considerations.
You might recall that in the
isoparametric formulation that
we discussed in the early
lectures, we used numerical
integration.
And this is an important fact,
and I want to discuss with you
in this lecture the Newton-Cotes
formulas that
we're using, and in particular,
the Gauss
integration--
the Gauss numerical integration
that we are using
in finite element analysis.
There are various
considerations.
First of all, I'd like to
present to you a little bit of
the theory that is being used
and in particular, however, I
also like to present to you some
practical considerations.
And finally, together with these
aspects, I would like to
also present to you some
considerations regarding the
choice of elements, and, of
course, regarding the choice
of the order of numerical
integration that has to be
used in the finite element
formulation.
Well, just to refresh your
memory, on this view graph, I
put together once the
various matrices
that we have to evaluate.
Here, we have to stiffness
matrix, which of course, is
obtained by the integral of
B transpose C, B. B is the
strain displacement
transformation matrix.
C is the stress strain law.
Of course, this B-matrix is a
function of x and y in the
physical space, but if you use
isoparametric interpolation in
two-dimensional analysis, this
B-matrix would be a function
of r and s, as we discussed
earlier.
The m matrix is given here, the
RB load vector is given
here, the RS load vector is
given here, and the initial
stress load vector
is given here.
We derived all of these
quantities in an earlier
lecture and all I like to now
discuss with you is how do we
evaluate these quantities using
numerical integration.
In isoparametric finite element
analysis, I mentioned
already the displacement
transformation matrix is a
function of r, s, and t.
The strain-displacement
interpolation matrix is also a
functional of r, s, and t in
three-dimensional analysis.
Of course, in one- or
two-dimensional analysis, we
only talk about r and
s, respectively.
Remember please, that r, s,
and t vary from minus 1 to
plus 1, and that we, therefore,
need the volume
transformation here, dV being
the determinant of J, where J
is a Jacobian transformation
between the x- and y-, and r-
and s-axis, or x-, y-, and z-
and r-, s-, and t-axis.
And of course, dr, dr, dt are
the respective differentiates
that have to be used
here, too.
We discussed that earlier, and
just to refresh your memory
again, what we came up with is
that the stiffness matrix K
two-dimensional analysis is
given in terms of of B
transpose C, B, times
determinant of J, dr, ds, and
we are integrating from
minus 1 to plus 1.
The mass matrix is given, as
shown here, where H is, of
course, once again,
the displacement
transformation matrix.
[? Row ?] is the mass density.
Just a preliminary thought,
please recognize that B
involves derivatives of
displacements, We have here
derivatives of displacements,
here we have the actual
displacements.
So the product of B transpose
B will, in general, be of
lower order than the product of
H transpose H. Therefore,
when we talk about numerical
integration, we will find that
to evaluate the M matrix
exactly, we will have to use a
higher order integration than in
the exact evaluation of the
stiffness matrix.
I will refer to that
again later.
We also mentioned already that
in the numerical integration,
the basic process is that we
are evaluating the function
Fij, as shown here, at
particular points, i, j,
denoted by i, j.
And the alpha i, j, are
weight coefficients.
Therefore, what we do is, once
again, to evaluate this
product at a particular point
within the element, multiply
that product by a weight
coefficient, and then do the
same for a certain selected
number of points, and sum all
these evaluations up, as
shown in this equation.
Now, what this means, of course,
is that we really have
to use specific points--
and I have to discuss with you
what points we are using--
and how many points is another
question that we
have to also discuss.
Well, in 2x2 integration, in
isoparametric finite element
analysis, we would use four
points altogether.
2x2 means two points
this direction, and
two points that direction.
In three- dimensional analysis,
we would, of course,
talk about 2x2x2.
You would have another two
points in this direction, in
the t direction.
These points in Gauss
integration, are given by
these values here.
In other words, point 4, for
example, would have the
values, r equals plus 0.577
and s equal to plus 0.577.
Point 1 would have the same
values, but both negative.
These values here are the
Gauss values, and I will
discuss briefly with you a
little later how these have
been obtained.
Of course, Gauss derived them
for us some 100 years ago, and
we are now simply using them.
In 3x3 integration, we talk
about nine integration points
altogether.
Once again, three integration
points lay, as so to say, in
this direction, and into
that direction.
If we use three-point
integration in
three-dimensional analysis, we
would have altogether 27
integration points because
each of these layers, of
course, applies then three
times, and because we also
have three layers into the t
direction, and therefore
altogether, 9x3, being 27
integration points.
The basic process of numerical
integration is that if we want
to integrate a function.
And I've shown here an actual
function-- this heavy line is
the actual function f-- if we
want to integrate that actual
function, with respect
to x here.
What we do is we are putting
an interpolating polynomial
down as an approximation
to that function.
Now, if we want to integrate
this function from a to b, the
simplest interpolating
polynomial would be to put a
straight line from this
point to that point.
And then the area under the
straight line is assumed to be
approximately, at least, really
sufficiently close, to
the area under the actual
function f.
So what we are doing then is we
are replacing the integral
of the actual function f, over
this integral, by the integral
of the interpolating polynomial
over that integral.
If we do that with just two
points, and the two points are
these two, we will derive
the trapezoidal rule.
If we use those three points,
and I have here a view graph
that shows how we would
use three points.
One point here, second point
there, and now we have also a
third point there.
Then we would obtain
the Simpson's rule.
Once again, instead of
integrating the actual
function, f, which is shown by
this line here, we are, in
fact, integrating the area
under this red line.
This is a little the weak.
Well, now there it comes.
We are integrating the area
under the red line.
In other words, the assumption
is then that this area is
close enough to the area under
blue line, and what we need to
do is to evaluate, of course,
the actual function, f, at
these three points.
And we will have to somehow
develop certain constants, the
alpha i, j's that I talked about
earlier that multiply
this function, f, in order to
evaluate the red area here
accurately.
Well, if we do that--
in other words, if we integrate
the red area using
these three function points then
we obtain the Simpson's
rule, and this is just one
rule of the more general
Newton-Cotes integration.
In the Newton-Cotes integration,
we use
equally-spaced sampling
points.
In other words, if we want to
integrate from a to b, the
simplest way of proceeding is to
use a sampling point here,
and a sampling point there.
And then, of course, as I
pointed out earlier, we are
putting, really, a straight line
down and we're assuming
that the area under this
straight line is equal to the
area to under the actual
function, f, that might be
looking like that.
Well, that is the trapezoidal
rule and Newton-Cotes
integration with n equal to 1.
In other words, with two
constants here, is equal to
this trapezoidal rule.
What we are saying is that the
area from a to b-- now I used
here r, this is the r-axis.
say, from a to b--
this is the actual
integration--
is replaced by the summation
of the value at this point,
the F0 value, the F1 value, and
each of these values is
multiplied by a certain
constant.
So in this particular case, for
the trapezoidal rules that
I'm talking about, the right
hand side looks as follows-- b
minus a, that is this length
here, times two values, the
C01, n is equal to 1 in this
particular case, times F0.
Plus C1 1 1 times F1.
And of course then, plus an
error, R in this particular
case, n, once again, is
equal to 1, plus R1.
This error of course, is assumed
to be very small in
the analysis, and we would
actually neglect it.
So once again, what we are
saying is that we can replace
the integration of F of R dr,
from a to b, via this
summation here.
Notice that b minus a times
that constant, that is our
alpha 1, that I referred
to earlier.
And b minus a times that
constant would be another
alpha value.
And, of course, these alpha
values here multiply the
actual function values at this
station, and at that station.
Well in the Simpson rule, n is
equal to 2, b minus a is still
there, but now we're talking
about C0 2 0 times F0 plus C1
2 times F1 plus C2 2 times
F2, and of course, an
error of 2's there.
Well, the constants, the
C0 1, C1 1 and so on.
The constant Cin have been
evaluated for us, and they are
tabulated in this table here.
Notice, that for the trapezoidal
rule, we have the
simple constants, 1/2, 1/2.
The error here is shown here,
10 to the minus 1 times the
second derivative of F. So if
the second derivative of the
actual function is 0, well, then
our integration is exact.
Of course, what that means is
that our function is indeed a
straight line.
Because only then the second
derivative is 0.
So our integration
is exact when we
integrate a straight line.
Well, if you look at our earlier
graph here, surely, if
our actual red line is a
straight line between this
point and that point, then our
integration, using the
trapezoidal rule,
must be exact.
And that is verified by looking
at the error bound,
given in this table.
The Simpson's rule has
constants, 1/6, 4/6, 1/6.
n is equal to 2 in this
particular case, as I
mentioned earlier.
The error here is now given
to the force derivative.
And so on.
Here, we have integrals
1 to 6.
In practice, however, we would
only use this the trapezoidal
rule, the Simpson rule, and
we might then still
use this rule here.
Notice that the error of this
rule here is of the same order
as the error of this rule,
involving five points.
So the four-point integration
rule, of course, is preferable
when you compare to the
five-point integration rule.
The other important point
is that if we use the
Newton-Cotes formally, we are
really always involving the
endpoints of the integration.
In other words, if we want to
integrate from a to b then we
will involve these two points
in the actual integration.
So if we talk about the
integration through the
thickness off the shell, or
through a beam element
thickness, then we would have
here the top and bottom
surfaces involved.
Bad point--
well, I shouldn't say bad, but
certainly it's not a very
advantageous point, of the
Newton-Cotes integration is
that we need to involve a
fairly large number of
integration points, or
integration point stations to
obtain an acceptable accuracy
when we talk about finite
element analysis.
And therefore, the Gauss
numerical integration is a
more attractive scheme.
And, in fact, we will find
that in finite element
analysis, we almost always use
Gauss numerical integration.
They're only certain special
cases in analysis of beams,
plates, and shells where we, in
fact, use the Newton-Cotes
integration.
And the reason then, of course,
is that we want to
obtain also surface stresses
and strains.
That would be, for example,
one reason.
Now, in Gauss numerical
integration, the basic concept
is quite similar to the concept
that we just discussed.
That we again use an
interpolating polynomial to
lay through the function over
the interval, a to b.
The important point, however,
now is that we use--
if we look at our
function here.
Here is the interval, a to b.
Our rx is here.
If you look at that function,
it's that we, in Gauss
numerical integration, do not
use equal-spaced intervals.
In Newton-Cotes integration, we
use equal-spaced intervals,
and involves the end points.
In Gauss numerical integration,
we are using
points, stations, 1 to 2, and
our stations that can be
anywhere in the interval.
And Gauss has developed the
optimum stations for us.
in other words, what he has
said, at that time is let us
optimize the particular
locations of the integration
points stations, and in
addition, let us optimize the
weights, alpha 1 to alpha n.
In the Newton-Cotes integration,
we only optimize,
so to say, the alpha values.
The stations were fixed because
we involved, for
example, in the trapezoidal
rule, we involved this end
point, and that point.
In the Simpson's rule,
we used the midpoint.
And so on.
In Gauss integration, we say,
well, let us does not
necessarily fix those stations
but rather let us just
optimize the location
of these stations.
Well, since we then can optimize
the values of the
alpha 1, to alpha n, this of
course are n, components, and
the stations R1 to Rn, which
are also n components.
We really can optimize
two n components.
Now, if we look at the fact that
we're dealing with two n
components that we optimize
now, and the fact that the
interpolating polynomial of
course, also involves one
constant, then we find that the
interpolating polynomial
can now be of order,
2n minus 1.
Whereas in the Simpson's rule,
the interpolating polynomial
with n stations could only
be of order, n minus 1.
You see, in the Simpsons rule,
for example, with three
stations, the n was, in the
Simpson's rule equal to 3, but
the order of the interpolating
polynomial was 2.
In other words, a parabola could
be integrated exactly.
Now in the Gauss integration,
we are talking about the
interpolating polynomial that
can be of order, 2n minus 1, a
much higher order
for n stations.
Here, with the Newton-Cotes rule
for n stations, we only
get an interpreting polynomial
of n minus 1.
Well, Gauss has developed the
specific stations, R1 to Rn,
to be used [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
in order to fit the
interpolating polynomial
through the actual function
that we want to integrate.
And of course, we also know
now the error that is
involved, Rn.
The error of course, being
much smaller than in the
Newton-Cotes formula because
we are dealing with a
higher-order interpolating
polynomial.
The Gauss values
are given here.
When n is equal to 1, well, we
only use the midpoint and the
alpha value is 2.
When n is equal to 2, in other
words, we are talking about
two-point integration, then
ri is equal to plus
minus 0.577, and 1.
In this particular case, we
are using the fact that we
want to integrate 4 minus
1, to plus 1.
In other words, our
r here, is this.
We coordinate here, and
we're integrating from
minus 1 to plus 1.
So in two-point integration, we
using a point here, which
is minus 0.577, and another
point here,
which is plus 0.577.
Notice that we are feeding in
these points to a higher-order
accuracy in a computer program,
typically, in a
computer program that runs
on a CDC machine
with 14-digit precision.
We would actually
put these points
in to 14-digit precision.
Of course, they are actually put
into this [? outputing. ?]
They are there, and the computer
program just picks up
this value and evaluates then,
of course, the function that
we want to integrate
at that station.
The factor that the function
has to be multiplied by is
given here.
In three-point integration,
we use three points.
This one is the easiest
to look at--
it's right to center point, and
then there are two more
points, one at minus 0.77
and one at plus 0.77.
In finite element analysis,
we know, of course, in
isoparametric finite element
analysis, I should really say,
we know, of course, that our
integration runs from
minus 1 to plus 1.
So these are the actual
values to be used.
And these are the actual values
that you would find,
for example, in the computer
program such as ADINA.
If we want to integrate an
interval from a to b--
I'd like to simply mention
that, of course, the same
scheme can directly be used.
If we have the ri and alpha i
for the interval from minus 1
to plus 1, then these would be
the value to be used for the
integration point stations.
If our interval is not from
minus 1 to plus 1. but from a
to b, and this would be the
weight that would have to be
used for this particular case.
The i in alpha i, once again,
are the same ri and alpha 1
that I listed here
in this table.
Well, so far we really talked
about one-dimensional
integration.
However, the same concept can
directly be used for multiple
dimension integration.
In other words, if we talk
about the integration,
minus 1 to plus 1.
For example, as we would
integrate, of course, in the
formation of a tress element.
If we now want to go through
the integration of a
two-dimensional element, then
we would have to integrate a
two-dimensional function in
r and s, and that means
integrating twice, once with
respect to r, once with
respect to s, and we can use the
same concept that we used
in [? analytical ?]
integrations, and we first
integrate with respect to r.
That gives us one alpha
i here, and then
with respect to s.
And the final result is shown
here, that we have to bring in
a weight factor, alpha i, and
a weight factor, alpha j.
This one for the i integration,
that one for the
a integration.
And of course, stations ri and
sj are the stations at which
we would evaluate the
actual function.
Notice one important point that
we could use a different
order of integration into
the two directions.
For example, if we have an
element such as this one,
two-dimension element,
two nodes
here, in the s direction.
But say three nodes in
the r direction.
So our r-axis is this one,
s-axis is that one.
Then in this particular case,
since we're using a higher
order interpolation into the r
direction, in this particular
case, we might say, well, let us
use three-point integration
this way, but two-point
integration into the s-axis.
So here, two-point integration
into the s-axis, but
three-point integration
into the r-axis.
And of course, the same concept
applies also in
three-dimensional analysis.
In three-dimensional analysis
as an example here, we would
have the F now being a function
of r, s, and t.
Three times integration from
minus 1 to plus 1.
And the final result just
derived the same way as in
two-dimensional analysis
as given here.
Notice once again, we can
use different orders of
integration into the
three directions.
I should also mention at this
point that when we talk about
an actual stiffness matrix, of
course, we talk about an
array, n by n, for
three-dimensional element, say
a 20-node brick.
This would be a 60 by 60
stiffness matrix, and every
one of these elements here, in
that stiffness matrix would be
an F, such an F. Every one of
these elements would be
integrated as shown here.
Let us now look at the practical
use of numerical
integration.
Well, the first important point
is that the order of
integration that is required to
evaluate a specific element
matrix can, of course, be
evaluated by studying the
function, f, to be integrated.
In other words, if I want to
evaluate a certain stiffness
matrix, K. Here is the stiffness
matrix given.
If I want to evaluate that
stiffness matrix exactly, I
could look at each all of these
elements, and there are
now many of these F functions
in there.
Let us look at that one.
I would look at that F value and
identify its dependency on
i, s, and t.
Linear, cubic, parabolic
and so on.
And then I could, by
entering into--
by the use of the Gauss numeric
integration, or the
Newton-Cotes integration, and
by looking up the errors
involved, I could identify what
integration order I need
in order to evaluate this
integral exactly.
That can be done and for simple
elements, relatively
simple elements--
in other words, 4-noded
elements, that are square, or
8-noded elements that
are square.
We can fairly simply evaluate
the order of integration that
is required.
However, when the element
is curved.
In other words, when we
talk about a general
elements like that--
the required integration order
is not that easily assessed,
in order to evaluate the
stiffness matrix exactly.
And the reason for it is that
we have the Jacobian
transformation in there.
Therefore, in practice, the
integration is frequently not
performed exactly, but we have
to remember that the
integration order must
be high enough.
Well, considering then the
evaluation of the element
matrices, we should notice the
following requirements.
For the stiffness matrix
evaluation, we note that the
element matrix should not
contain any spurious zero
energy modes.
What do I mean by that?
Well, I mean that if I have
an element such as
that element here.
We know that if you're talking
about a plane stress element,
there only three rigid
body modes.
One rigid translation this way,
one rigid translation
that way, and one rigid
rotation of the
elements that way.
These are the only three rigid
body modes that the element
stiffness matrix
should contain.
It should, of course, contain
these in order to satisfy the
convergence requirements that
we discussed earlier.
What I'm saying now is that my
integration order should be
high enough so that there is
no additional 0 igon value.
If there is an additional 0 igon
value, I might run into
serious numerical difficulties
in the solution of the overall
governing equilibrium
equations.
And I will give you just now
a very simple example.
The second requirement is that
the element stiffness matrix
should contain the required
constant strain states.
So basically, what I'm saying
here is that the numerically
integrated stiffness matrix
should still contain the
requirements that we discussed,
which the element
must satisfy for convergence.
For the mass matrix evaluation,
here we only need
to satisfy that the total
mass must be included.
In other words, the numerical
integration should pick up the
actual mass of the element.
If that were not the case, then
considering the total
analysis, we would have
lost some mass.
The force vector evaluation
valuation here, also is a
total loads.
Must be included, must be picked
up, so to say, by the
numerical integration.
Let us look at this requirement
here, and then I
have a very simple example.
Here we have the 8-node element,
plane stress element,
which is supported here
on a hinge, and
here on a stiff string.
I apply a load, p, there.
If I use 2x2 Gauss integration,
I get absurd results.
If I use 3x3 Gauss
integration, I
get the correct results.
The correct results, of
course, being that the
elements simply rotates
about this point, a.
It simply rotates about the
point, a, as a rigid body.
And, of course, extending
in that rotation's a
spring at point b.
The absurd results
here come about--
using 2x2 integration--
because the stiffness matrix k
does not contain just three
rigid body modes, but four rigid
body modes, with 2x2
Gauss integration.
Now, three rigid body modes are
suppressed by the hinge
here and the spring there,
they are suppressed.
But if I look at the fact that
we are now having four in the
stiffness matrix, if I suppress
three, I still am
left with one rigid body
mode, and that
means one 0 igon value.
So this is still an unstable
structural stiffness matrix,
and when I subject that
stiffness matrix two a load p,
I get absurd results.
Therefore, this is a very
simple example that
demonstrates that the Gauss
integration has to be high
enough in order to prevent
instabilities occurring in the
solution of the equations.
In practice, of course, what
happens frequently is that we
are using these elements in a
mesh, so we have an 8-node
element here, and another
8-node element here.
And if we use 2x2 integration
for this element, 2x2
integration for that element, we
might very well be able to
solve the equations very nicely,
and we might, in fact
get good results in a analysis
of a more complicated problem.
Because the stiffness of this
element and that element,
they, each other, compensate
for the loss for the rigid
body mode that is still
available in
this one element here.
In other words, although this
one element is unstable, when
you look at it numerically, when
we solve the equations
for a single element,
as shown here.
When the element is surrounded
by other elements, they
provide enough stiffness into
this element so that the
overall solution of the mesh can
still be obtained, and we
obtain, in fact, good results.
However, if you do use reduced
integration, we call this
reduced integration because
we are not evaluating the
stiffness matrix exactly.
If you do use reduced
integration, you should be
aware of this fact that for
a single element, or for a
certain element mesh layouts,
we can run into numerical
difficulties.
Let's look briefly at the
stress calculations.
Surely, stresses can be
calculated at any
point of the element.
And they would be evaluated
as shown here.
The stress strain law is here.
Here we have to the
strain-displacement
interpolation matrix.
Here, we have seen the nodal
point displacement vector.
Of course, these nodal points
displacements are now known,
they are now given.
This is an initial stress vector
which is also given.
You should notice that the
stresses are, in general,
discontinuous across
element boundaries.
If we look at a [? practical ?]
analysis, we
might actually not evaluate the
stresses at the boundary
of an element, but we might
evaluate the stresses at the
integration points.
So if you look at a mesh of
elements, as shown here.
We might evaluate the stresses
at the 2x2 integration points,
shown here for that element.
If we were to evaluate the
stresses of this element at
this boundary, and of this
element at that boundary, we
would see a stress jump.
I should mention here, just as a
side note, that in fact, one
can show that the stresses at
the Gauss integration points
are somewhat better predicted
in a finite element analysis
than along the boundary
of the element.
So that is another reason why we
use, rather, why we predict
stresses rather, at the Gauss
integration points, and not on
the boundaries of the element,
using directly this approach.
As an example here, let us look
at a very simple problem.
Here we have a cantilever
modeled
with two 8-node elements.
Now remember, that these two
8-node elements each contain
the parabolic displacement
variation.
So since this is a bending
moment that we apply to that
cantilever, and since this
bending moment, of course,
gives parabolic displacement
variationn The finite element
solution would be correct,
will be exact in this
particular case.
And therefore, there would
be no stress jump here.
Since the elements contain the
displacements that shall be
predicted, that are the
analytically-correct results.
The finite element mesh will
predict these displacements,
and, of course, we have
stress continuity.
This is shown here by--
we have dissected these
elements here.
This is element 2, this
is here, element 1.
And we have plotted the stress
distribution along
the line a, b, c.
Here's the line, a, b, c.
And as you can see,
there's 900 here,
and there's 900 there.
And of course, a linear
variation stresses, so no
stress jumps there.
However, if you look at the
same problem, the same
cantilever, I should say, with
now an edge share load, as
shown here.
Then these elements cannot
represent the exact
displacement distribution in
the cantilever because they
only contain a parabolic
variation in displacement.
And in this case, we have the
stress discontinuity.
tau x x, in other words, the
stress into this direction
here, so normal stress.
For this element along, for
element 2, along a,b,c, you
can see 1744 up there.
And then [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
a neutral axis because
of symmetry
conditions, of course.
And for element 1, along a, b,
c, we have 1502 right there.
So there is, in fact, this
stressed discontinuity that I
was talking about earlier.
The share stresses here have
also a slight discontinuity,
as you can see, 291.38,
296.48.
The reason that we have this
stress discontinuity here is,
of course, that the
elements cannot
represent the exact solution.
And therefore, they each try to,
in the integral sense of
the finite element formulation,
try to predict
the solution accurately within
its domain, and the result is
that we have a stress
discontinuity between elements.
Finally, let us look then at
some modeling considerations.
In order to solve a problem,
we should really have a
qualitative knowledge of the
response to be predicted.
We should also have a thorough
knowledge of the principles of
mechanics and the finite element
procedures available.
And this, of coure, is
the subject of my
lectures here to you.
If we have these two knowledges,
then we should
still know a little bit more
about what kind of elements we
should use, how one element
performs versus another.
And here, the first remark that
I like to make is that
parabolic undistorted elements
are usually most effective.
Here, please see that I'm saying
usually most effective
because in some earlier lecture,
I talked about the
analysis of fracture mechanics
problems, where we, in fact,
distort elements to pick up
stress singularities.
But if we don't talk about
stress singularities or
special situations, usually
the parabolic undistorted
elements are most effective.
Here, I have put together in a
table the kinds of elements
that I would recommend
for usage.
These are typically also the
elements that I used in
general purpose code
such ADINA.
Tress or cable element,
the 2-node
element is quite effective.
In some cases, we want to use
a three-node element or
four-node element, but the
2-node element is cheap and
very effective in modeling.
For two-dimensional plane
stress, plane strain,
axisymetric analysis, the 8-node
or 8-node element.
Those are the elements most
effective, and as I just
mentioned, we should use them
undistorted, in other words,
rectangular.
The three-dimensional
analysis then.
In three-dimensional analysis,
we would effectively use the
20-node brick element, which is
really the counterpart of
the 8- or 9-node element.
For the 3D that is curved, we
would use three-moded elements
or four-noded elements-- better
even four-noded elements.
Of course, if we have a straight
beam, then we would
use simply the engineering
[? animation, ?]
two-noded beam.
But if you talk about a curved
beam, then the isoparametric
beam that I presented to you in
lecture 7 is very effective.
The plate and shell elements
that I would recommend are
this element here, for
plate analysis--
I mentioned that already
earlier.
And for the shell analysis, the
nine-noded element and the
16-node element.
Even for plates, it might pay
sometimes to use the 16-node
element, which is very
effective, and particularly
works for very, very thin
plates and shells.
It does not have the
deteriorating behavior of the
locking phenomenon that I
referred to in lecture 7.
Let us look also at some
mesh considerations.
If we perform an analysis, we
might find that in some area
of the element idealization.
We want to use 4-node elements
lower order elements, and in
another area, we want to use
higher order elements.
Well, here, I've show a
transition region going from a
4- to a 5-node to take
an 8-node element.
Notice that we have full
compatibility along this side.
So this is a comparable element
transition from 4- to
8-node elements.
And similarly, of course, in
three-dimensional analysis,
you could go from 8-node bricks
to 20-node bricks by
using such transition
elements.
An alternative approach would
be to use a 4-node element
here, and say, two 4-node
elements there, but notice
that if you do so, the
displacements at node a, have
to be constraint, if you
want to preserve
compatibility here.
Notice that along BC, for this
4-node element, we have a
linear variation and
displacements because we have
only UB, VB, UC, VC there.
And of course, here, for these
two 4-noded elements, we have
a linear varition from here to
there, and another linear
variatoin from here to there
in displacements.
To preserve full compatibility
along this line, these two
constraint equations
have to be used.
And that means, really, that VA
and UA are set to the mean
of UB, UC, and VB, BC,
as shown here.
Another transition approach is
shown here on the last view
graphs that I wanted
to present to you.
And here we're going from 8-node
elements, or 7-node
elements, if you wanted to use
8-noded elements here, then of
course, we would have to put
another node in there each.
So here we're going from two
layers of 8-node elements,
over into one layer of
8-node not elements.
Notice that in this particular
transition region here, we are
using a distorted element.
Of course, that means the order
of accuracy that we can
expect here in the stress
predictions and so on, is not
quite as good as we would
like to see it.
So this transition region should
be away from the area
of interest. the area of
interest being somewhere over
here, far way from the
transition reason.
However, we do have a compatible
element layout, and
that, of course, is an important
point, which I
mentioned to you earlier, that
we would like to preserve
compatibility as much
as possible.
And for that reason, of course,
we have developed
these variable number
node elements.
This concludes what I wanted
to say in this lecture.
Thank you for your attention.